- I'm gonna ask you guys
here if you could hear
a rap about anything in the
world what would it be about?
So everyone think of a
word, a topic or a phrase
you'd like to hear a rap about.
There are three rules, number one no food,
number two no animals.
they're the most common
suggestions our brains think of
don't say dog or cheese you know.
The number three, don't be too obvious.
Don't say Brexit or Trump,
don't say the Queen,
don't say at the Revolutionary War,
'cause I still feel
quite bitter about that.
(crowd laughs)
The best suggestion anyone ever said
was Ninth Century crop rotation.
(crowd laughs)
Just so you know, that's the
intellectual high ground,
you can aim for that if you want.
I will take five suggestions,
I'll divide the room up
so everyone gets a fair go.
I will come to this segment first.
What do you wanna hear a rap about guys?
- [Woman] Teacher.
- Teacher, well are you a teacher?
- [Woman] Yeah
- What do you teach?
- [Woman] Marine Bio, Marine Biology
- Oh, thank you very much
for, you said Marine Bio
and then I looked to you
being like "I didn't yeah."
As if I didn't know what bio was
no that's okay, I just didn't know.
Aren't you like a professor then?
- [Woman] Yes Sir.
- Yes, so don't do yourself down.
You're a professor, that's cool.
Yeah that's cool, good, cool.
What a tense interaction
this is for some reason.
(crowd laughs)
I just never met a Marine biologist,
who refers to themselves as a teacher,
rather than as a professor,
cool that's cool.
So a professor of Marine
biology great suggestion.
Guys, let's try and be less threateningly
aggressive towards me from now on.
(crowd laughs)
This side of the middle, what
do you wanna hear a rap about?
- [Man] Shakespeare.
- Shakespeare.
Is there a particular
aspect of Shakespeare,
particular play that intrigues you?
- [Woman] "Othello."
- "Othello."
Thank you very much for helping
the personnel over there.
(crowd laughs)
Like, that prick doesn't know any plays.
Okay, cool.
"Othello" so is that one of
your favorite Shakespeare plays?
- [Woman] Yes.
- Cool, what's your favorite?
Which favorite character in "Othello?"
- [Woman] "Othello."
- Okay well.
(crowd laughs)
Really any idiot could
say that, couldn't they?
(crowd laughs)
Who's your favorite
character in "The Lion King?"
"The Lion King" actually.
(crowd laughs)
Cool, so a professor of Marine biology,
Othello, let's come to you guys over here.
What do you want a rap about"
- [Woman] Borderline Personality Disorder.
- Borderline Personality Disorder.
When I was a young man living in London,
I used to work for a
mental health charity,
and I knew nothing about
borderline personality disorder.
Then I interviewed a woman with it.
I was like, "Oh, it's probably really fun.
"She probably does all
these different things."
Then I was like, "So tell me
about how it's affected you."
She was like "Wanted
to put my baby in an."
(crowd laughs)
True facts.
- Cool BPD and that's what it's called?
The acronym, that's what the
people in the know call it.
Guys over here what you want a rap about?
Bearing in mind that so far we've had
three of the driest suggestions
I've ever been served up.
Well okay, so there were two suggestions.
You said gigolos and hoes.
And you said red-light
district in Amsterdam
almost as if you have a telepathic link.
Liverpool is kind of included
in the hoes aspect of that.
(crowd laughs)
You don't know this, but
Liverpool is a great city.
Go and visit it.
It genuinely is, I'm a
big fan of Liverpool.
So, I feel that gigolos and
hoes and red light strip
in Amsterdam kind of all bundle into one.
So the red-light district in Amsterdam
with the gigolos and hoes,
Marine biology professors, "Othello"
BPD, let's get one final one.
And I'm gonna say, let's
make this real good.
And we can come to the back of the room.
'Cause I figured you guys got left out,
right back at the room what
do you wanna hear a rap about?
- [Man] Population growth.
- Population growth.
(crowd laughs)
And I love how you ended that
on like a rising inflection
kind of you know,
mirroring what is happening
with population at the moment.
It's about every 10
seconds, like 40 births
and about 11 deaths.
It's unsustainable guys, just so you know.
I'm afraid population growth,
beat you to the punch there.
(crowd laughs)
Although we do need another
agricultural revolution
to support the population growth
on this overburden planet.
So this is what you want
on a Friday, isn't it?
Just five things, I mean one
of them admittedly quite fun.
You know, red-light district but the rest
of them really just a somber mood.
(crowd laughs)
Okay. Well, we're gonna
have some fun with them,
what I'm gonna do, I'm going
to take all those suggestions
and putting them into an
incredible freestyle rap
made up on the spot,
none of it's prepared.
None of it's written,
none of it is rehearsed.
It will be about the red-light
district in Amsterdam,
population growth, "Othello"
borderline personality disorder,
and Marine biologist professors.
And don't worry you don't be
anywhere near as atrociously
bad as you're expecting
a privately educated
middle-class white boy to be.
(crowd laughs)
Thank you very much.
Those either are on board with this,
if we can drop the beat good sir,
let's have some fun.
(gentle music)
Everyone's sitting there, silent and going
What the heck is gonna happen
(gentle music)
(upbeat music)
♪ Yeah, dispersed knowledge ♪
♪ Standing at the classroom ♪
♪ Sitting in the college ♪
♪ Got a blackboard making
sure my students all know ♪
♪ If to the seaside they might go ♪
♪ Look over there I offer an apology ♪
♪ Sea level rising,
more biology to study ♪
♪ That's a good thing even if we drowned ♪
♪ I like it get my boat
my team we go down ♪
♪ Look at the Marine life it's so nice ♪
♪ Study Marine biology my advice ♪
♪ It's to make sure you
stay away from the shore ♪
♪ Get down deep right to the sea floor ♪
♪ Workout, scuba dive and be hench ♪
♪ Maybe dig down, deep
right into a trench ♪
♪ The sea life there, you
couldn't have observed it ♪
♪ So many species much more than varden ♪
♪ Than anywhere else you might discover ♪
♪ Angler fish maybe sea cucumbers ♪
♪ Giving threats when they feel scared ♪
♪ If I wanna see ladies with bread ♪
♪ Press some buttocks, yeah I venture ♪
♪ To Amsterdam, I'm
going there in December ♪
♪ To do a show, not to get wild ♪
♪ I've got the face of
a very young child ♪
♪ That will go right up to the windows ♪
♪ And say check out the
gigolos and the hoes oh ♪
♪ I look at the hips
they sway, side to side ♪
♪ The red-light district ♪
♪ And so well you're into me ♪
♪ I take my wallet ♪
♪ I say which girls
really, really want it ♪
♪ They all turn their
backs then they go inside ♪
♪ I'm like, wow that
reaction was extra snide ♪
♪ They didn't want nothing to do with me ♪
♪ I flip on a dime, like a got BPD ♪
♪ I'm not making light
of an actual illness ♪
♪ It's really horrible when I discussed ♪
♪ This with a lady who cooked her baby ♪
♪ I was like, oh no that bitch crazy ♪
♪ But that's not the sensitive way ♪
♪ So I was more somber
with the words I say ♪
♪ I say wow, what a
really difficult time ♪
♪ You didn't know which part
of your life was dying ♪
♪ Dying a word used by Shakespeare 1600s ♪
♪ Yeah, come here ♪
♪ We got a nice show called Othello ♪
♪ Is he black or is he
white, you won't know ♪
♪ Until you go there
standing on the floor ♪
♪ There was no seats, wow ♪
♪ Look at this more
from Morocco and Iago ♪
♪ He's the antagonist we all know ♪
♪ Desdemona she was the lady ♪
♪ About her affection when crazy ♪
♪ Othello was like, I
like her Iago said too ♪
♪ But then he had a plan
that he started to brew ♪
♪ He wanted to betray him
'cause he felt offended ♪
♪ He was like this guy
that I had befriended ♪
♪ If you don't know the
plot there's no hope ♪
♪ I try and explain population growth ♪
♪ Now in the world like 7.6 ♪
♪ The clock moves on
billions just clicks ♪
♪ Where are people? Are
you going to find there ♪
♪ Probably in India, probably in China ♪
♪ Population growth
going through the roof ♪
♪ If you're in Japan
I'll tell you the truth ♪
♪ It's actually declining by 1.5 ♪
♪ Hard to see how the
population could survive ♪
♪ No thriving people get into a couple ♪
♪ And then they say yeah ♪
♪ We'll have less than a
couple of kids just one ♪
♪ But how do you do 0.5
it doesn't make sense ♪
♪ I'm gonna hand jive and wave around ♪
♪ And say we must, we'll
fix the population growth ♪
♪ Elon Musk could save it ♪
♪ He would help us come from a far ♪
♪ Move the population right up to Mars ♪
♪ Hey be like yeah, earth
we should abandon it ♪
♪ And start new population
on the Red Planet ♪
There you go.
(crowd applauding)